j'accueille zouzou et fabrice gaignault
qu'est ce qui lie à chaud avant mais
avec les mici s'écoule alors fabrice
gaignault bonsoir et écrivain on vous
doit la chasse à l'âme à la table ronde
journaliste rédacteur en chef culture
chez marie-claire et où publié chez
fayard
égérie sixties très bon bouquin très bon
bouquin très très belle somme vous où
vous êtes une égérie sixties soulageant
de suzuka tous ici alors c'est jerry
sixties par exemple anita pallenberg
c'est écrit en gros en fait j'ai
commencé effectivement mon travail en
rencontrant anita pallenberg à londres
en faisant un reportage pour marie
claire et en discutant avec elle elle
était dans sa dans sa chambre d'hôtel
il se trouve que marianne faithfull
était dans le même hôtel au même moment
donc je me suis aperçu que tous ces gens
se continuer à se voir voilà c'est ça
exactement et anita j'ai passé deux
jours avec elle discutait à
l'interviewer et m'a dit à un moment
mais dans le fond on parle toujours des
rolling stones des beatles et des kings
souder ou ou des genres du cinéma de
l'époque mais pas tellement de nous de
l'importance qu'on a eue a également
auprès de ces gens cette époque c'est
vrai voilà ce qu'a été la maîtresse de
voyenne john de kif et charles
évidemment marine fait foule maîtresses
de mick jagger nico et puis philippe
garrel voilà après dany on connaît tous
ici
tina hautmont ces kits il a au moins
alors tina au monde c'est la fille
jean pierre aumont et de marié mon test
qui était qui est décédé à ces jeunes
enfin dans sa baignoire on n'a jamais su
si elle était morte de mort naturelle ou
sucer des dîners moment à une enfance
assez triste elle était mise en pension
suisses éloigné de de son père donc et
très vite vers 16 17 ans elle a
rencontré christian marquand way qu'elle
épouse est pratiquement ce moment là
donc est là elle est devenue aussi elle
a fait du cinéma qu'elle est devenue une
personnalité assez emblématique de cette
épreuve amanda lear tout le monde la
connaît 1
c'était d'ailleurs là pour être dans
votre bouquin les animaux qui changent
de sexe endormir saluant caroline de
bendern or là je la connais pas du tout
à fait ordinaire c'est celle qui est
devenue la fameuse marianne rouge
elle a été immortalisé par une photo on
la voit sur les épaules de jean jacques
lebel en train de défiler lors d'une
manifestation contre la guerre du
vietnam avec le drapeau viet congs et
c'était un mannequin elin
beaucoup étaient chez catherine
merveille absolue que celle-ci en fait
mon livre commence à se sont rencontrés
chez catherine harley il y avait les
anita pallenberg amanda lear anna karina
zouzou alors pattie boyd de femme de
george harrison influent d'eric clapton
laptop et zhu zhu zhu ici présente donc
égérie des sixties alors avant de zoomer
sur quelques-unes de ses égéries des
sixties
elle avait quoi en commun alors déjà
quand on lit votre bouquin on s'aperçoit
qu'elle désirait pas le elle désirait
pas le bonheur qu'elle considérait comme
un produit marketing
mais elle elle voulait vivre vite elle
arrive en plus à une époque elles ont 20
25 ans à une époque où il ya la société
gaulliste est encore assez fermé ouais
et elles vont me servant 68 ouais il n'y
a pas encore la pilule la pilule
arrivants 67
elle repousse sans cesse les limites
d'une liberté qu'ils auraient été assez
fermé à l'époque et qui conservait ses
premiers points soit main ou absolument
ensuite pas d'engagement politique
pendant 68 à oman a érigé la seule
barricades qu'il ya eu qu'à eues à rome
par exemple en 68 et toi et on a parlé
elle a fait un peu mais c'était là c'est
l'unité
alors en fait leur seule ambition dans
la vie c'est s était de s'amuser
elles ont fait des films elle était
assez velléitaire elle pouvait refuser
de se lever pour r1 fille et nous faire
un enregistré une chanson c'était pas
c'est aussi l'époque où il y avait très
peu de chômage
ouais pratiquement il n'y a pas de
pratiquement pas de chômage il avait 62
donc les gens se rencontrait chez castel
souvent la nuit 17 sièges et un petit
rôle pour toi le lendemain tu peux
commencer à travailler comme croyable
une époque de fête en fête une époque où
finalement et beaucoup d'insouciance
beaucoup de justement pourquoi deux faut
faire un effort
vous dites elles ressemblent à des
versions rock and roll de la goulue ou
de kiki de montparnasse sabres sgp assez
ça ressemble un petit peu ce qu'on a dit
sur toi par exemple tag white un facteur
ont parlé c'est oui c'est ce que disait
du kovic jeune homme avait lancé vrai
effectivement pas tout on peut peut-être
pas dire sa demande à lire quoi qu'elle
se verrait bien le la montaise à la fin
de sa vie alors importance évidemment
donc du rock du swinging london qui à
l'époque était câble la mecque la mecque
du monde
il ya une phrase j'ai pu tirer mais vous
dites là la seule chose vraiment
importante qui soit arrivée en france
dans les années 60 c'est neil gaullisme
l'île mauri
mais l influence de l'angleterre et
c'est vrai alors ce qui était amusant
c'est que tous ces gens enfin ce petit
milieu partait le plus possible les week
end c'était en bateau
colloque à londres pour passer un week
end à découvrir les kingsley où cette
musique là moi j'appelle ça la nouvelle
france libre en fête la ligue gaullisme
et puis c'est vrai j'en ce très bonne
image auxerre alors alita pallenberg
donc alex de brian jones de quitterie de
chardes celle qui fait découvrir aux
stones le h comme incroyable la mode oui
warhol ginsburg oui ils vont vraiment à
bertoua et la culture
ouais parce que anita comme certaines
autres
de ses égéries en fait avait un beau
coup de culture background culturel ce
que n'avait pas évidemment les rockeurs
qui avait fait ça depuis qu'ils avaient
16 10 et khaled en milieu c'est simple
caroline de bendern anita venait d'une
très bonne famille ça son
arrière-grand-père était un peintre très
connu star
donc elle elle me dit qu'elle a beaucoup
marianne faithfull n'en parlons pas avec
beaucoup ont apporté les livres par
exemple la poésie anglaise toutes sortes
de choses ce qui a influé la chanson
bien évidemment bien sûr alors elle vit
ensuite avec keith richards da
villefranche rien et comme du bruit émis
à quoi mais riche quoi comme des moyens
assez assez fortuna seniors les six mois
huit mois passés à dans la villa
nellcôte reste des mois d'anthologie
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de
choses alors c'est elle qui a eu l'idée
du look de kate chrétiens d'en pâtir le
col autour des yeux
voilà les cheveux qu'il cache ses
oreilles a fait sa petite veste biba
élus avaient dessiné son pantalon de
cuir lacée cet acte il a cousu succès
alors pour mieux garder qui sait les
stones les accroche et l'héroïne est en
fait c'est elle qui s'accroche plus que
les autres exactement
c'était le revers de la médaille c'est
qu'elle est restée elle est restée
accrochée assez longtemps effectivement
alors nico qui reste comme une des
grandes égéries sixties
en fait vous vous dites joujoux high
tone et les discours fasciste
un soir j'étais allé voir tim hardin à
la fac d'assas et je savais pas qu'elle
passait en première partie le rideau
sous nico était là et je la vois comme
un jeu long qui commence à enchanter
deutschland über alles
j'ai eu les boules je me suis cassé ce
que du trône maintenant c'est non quand
elle avait bu
le premier degré sortait l'album parce
qu'elle faisait croire péter douanes
était allemande en fait alors mind fait
foule donc était avec mick jagger alors
évidemment qui s'est complètement
accroché à 0 contre actions ordinaires
est sorti à chaque fois elle est venue
sdf c'est assez hard la descente un
joule à la régulière moment c'était
assez dur des années 70 début 80 lorsque
vous vous avez rendu dingue jean paul
goude et jack nicholson bernardo
bertolucci vous étiez la reine de saint
germain des prés j'ai unique ouvert à
tous et merci à vous de juger vraiment
là un oui bertolucci que j'ai eu
longuement vue mais dit mais moi j'étais
amoureux pendant des années d'une femme
s'était c'était où il a suivi au
festival de cannes dans les petites rues
il à suivre est il a suivi en italie
dans un festival de cinéma il a continué
à lui écrire il était branché avec brian
jones j'ai vécu deux ans ouais et brian
jones vous a dit cette phrase terrible
j'ai fondé le groupe et je me fais virer
comme un malpropre
vous dites qu'il ait tué par la drogue
évidemment mais aussi par le père des
dépravations qu'il vivait avec son
copain de laquelle mel c koi travail
assez c'était quelqu'un d'assez comment
dire malléable et en même temps assez
assez faible et en même temps très
sensible et s'est retrouvé dans d'un
avec donald cammell dans cette espèce de
tripes sado maso qui qu'elle n'était pas
du tout préparé
et ça l'a complètement avait fait une
cure en l'air mais bon après il ya eu la
rupture qui sait avec annie avec anita
qui s'est passé d'une façon la quitter
pour qui ce futur s'attendait pas à ça
non plus et et je me souviens est
toujours un jour il m'appelle il dit
elle
c'est mon anniversaire je lui dis je
sais elle me dit qu'est ce que tu en
penses anita via nîmes offrir un fouet à
judy gens pensent qu'elle nous l'avons
bien qu il a pu s'en servent
m et il a fait quoi et devant un cd avec
moi c'est un petit prince louis dans la
conclusion la plus belle conclusion je
trouve c'est celle de maurice et le
sillage de la factory qui dit la plus
belle chose que ces femmes auront réussi
ça leur mort et c'est vrai que par
rapport à toutes ces rockstars qui sont
éternels qu'ils sont immortels
les filles elles ont reçu quoi c'est la
constante de ce livre c'est que les
filles vraiment beaucoup morfler ils
s'en remettent enfin certaines vraiment
merci très bien 12 ou amanda vrai et
donc de l'argent un peu moins bien parce
que c'était plus entière pourquoi ils
ont plu et je pense oui c'est vrai qu on
allait vraiment et c'est intéressant
le bus can fabrice parce que il met en
exergue toutes ces filles là qu existent
et il ya plus de filles moi je cherche
je vois kate moss ou béatrice dalle vers
la dette
oui oui vous à votre enfance a été
bercée par par cette musique par les
beatles les stones les kinks et yardbird
1 milliard d'eur soit riolas et et en
fait on comprend en lisant le bouquin
que votre mère a été l'une de ces bornes
c'était quelqu'un qui ressemblait
beaucoup à ce n'était pas une égérie
connu mais c'était une égérie d'un d'une
petite bande et c'était quelqu'un qui
ressemblait beaucoup par exemple à anita
physiquement quand elle était joué ça
m'a beaucoup frappé mais après c'est
drôle tsuji corps et ses livres en fait
quand on écrit une biographie on se
demande enfin il ya toujours des raisons
souterraine et chaussures y tient moi je
m'intéresse temps à ces femmes et
c'est vrai que elle évoque beaucoup ma
mère il se paru assez vite
elle trouve un tragique votre mairie la
drogue l'alcool la drogue les
médicaments
c'est un peu une façon mais qui a très
bien vécu ouais c'est année la visite en
réussissant un passé j'ai déterré des
fantômes quoi donc c'est une façon en
même temps jorane de raconter cette
épopée de danse est parée de vous
retrouver que c'est drôle parce que
frédéric botton m'a appelé en disant que
c'était extrêmement gay etc
je pense qu'il ya aussi un côté
mélancolique dont livre une anecdote
d'ailleurs que boat on vous raconte dans
le bouquin au sujet de marie france pour
donner un état d'esprit de l'époque
c'est marie france donc il rencontre
nathis et il lui dit je te fais un
cadeau et tu saches que je t'offre ce
que tu veux et tu es fou d'amour de
marie-france onasis et elle je lui dis
autrement et des perruques alors votons
l'uimm enfin si tu veux tu peux avoir ce
que tu es le mecs et au nazisme et
procréative et dépérit qu'elle lui
réponds parce que c'est à la mode c'est
ça c'est tout et c'est extraordinaire
s'est fini très très très bien l'époque
complètement une espèce d'année folle
comme ont pu être les années vingt dix
ont complètement parti d'une phrase
enfin c'est drôle de keith richards
turin ita c'est anita c'est la première
à se faire sauter la dernière à se faire
payer
ouais train de faire sous l'oeil de la
langue et de paix absolument
sa saison
vive la fête
à une fillette
m
programme sinon